business has rarely been so unpopular
capitalism is in serious disrepute a lot
of people are convinced that businesses
as their structure today simply don't
properly serve our best collective
interests yet a world without business
scarcely seems realistic the challenge
isn't to do away with business its to
feel our way towards a better version
here are five things we think are
necessary for decent humane and
profitable business culture as human
beings there are things we need and that
are genuinely good and important for our
flourishing and then there are things we
merely desire that appeal to our
appetites but aren't connected up with
anything sincere or worthwhile the
problem is we aren't good at identifying
and holding on to the distinction we're
not very good at knowing what's really
good for us this has created a great
temptation for capitalism for the
standard capitalist it doesn't matter
much what you make your money from it
could be needs or desires you could be
selling shoelaces crude oil
nanotechnology handguns the collected
works of Tolstoy this is the classic
defense for selling [ __ ] capitalism
has not traditionally been interested in
the source of its profits the idea is to
make money from supplying whatever
people happen to be willing to pay for
but capitalism becomes evil when it
explodes our inability to distinguish
our needs from our desires when large
numbers of businesses sell people stuff
that they desire which in all honesty
they don't need so as a first basic
point good businesses should be defined
not simply by whether they're profitable
or not but by what they make their
profit from only businesses that satisfy
our true needs immoral
it's hard to make any business work it's
doubly hard to make it work when you're
trying not only to make money but also
to make it from needs rather than
desires bigger fortunes could be made
faster selling french fries than
stone-ground bread or running gossipy
sensationalizing newspapers than serious
broadsheets
strip clubs make more money than book
shops status driven luxury brands are
more successful than Fairtrade
cooperatives it's harder to make things
which are both appealing and good
because the enterprise need to solve two
big problems rather than just one the
laurel producer has to master both
seduction and goodness lots of people
have mastered seduction think of how
good those ice cream and doughnut
manufacturers are at eroding our
willpower and better natures and a fair
number of people have mastered goodness
think of those worthy or steer people
who work in ecological services or run
websites bringing news of appalling
misdeeds in the factories of the
developing world but very few have
mastered both arts seduction and
goodness it's not impossible it's not
the goodness makes seduction impossible
or the seduction rules out goodness it's
just that the target is smaller and far
far harder to hit but that's what we
need to aim for the great challenge of
our age is to make goodness not just its
own reward but also deeply appealing to
many to fuse goodness and seduction in
the Utopia relationship therapy would
therefore end up having some of the
charm of a gelateria
what we want above all from our work
money aside is that it be meaningful
what is meaningful work a meaningful job
is any occupation which gives you a
feeling that you are in some way through
your labour either reducing suffering or
increasing the level of fulfillment of
others that you are leaving the world a
slightly better place than you found it
the more meaningful a job the less money
matters people will be ready to enlist
in the army and die for the defence of
their nation for a very low salary or
think of the sacrifices made by
explorers environmentalists nurses or
people at the literary end of publishing
motivation comes from serving and Noble
cause good businesses are those who
reward their employees not just with
cash but also with that equally valuable
currency meaning many people at the top
of capitalism already have enough money
to feed 12 generations and yet still
they push for high returns 30 percent
per annum rather than 3 which would be
enough to keep ahead of inflation the
important thing to grasp is that though
these captains of business want to make
money deep down if they understood
themselves better they'd realize they
aren't in it for the sake of the money
what they really want is to respect
honor and love that comes in our society
for having been known to have made lots
of money this holds out an important
clue for how we should reform society by
making honor and respect more reliably
available to those capitalists who
choose to run their businesses in noble
ways satisfying needs not desires and
giving meaning to their workforces the
way status is currently distributed
directly rewards the worst kinds of
capitalism it directs honor to wealth
without asking skeptically enough how
the wealth was accumulated that's
something we're all responsible for when
we pay undue attention to the yachts and
the parties how impressed we are by
money is part of what keeps business
people who are generally narcissistic
ego driven personalities going people
become moral capitalists when they can
accept a lower return on capital in the
name of producing meaning kindness and
goodness and we become a moral Society
when we give honor and respect not just
for those who've made a lot of cash any
old how those who made a bit of cash
doing good things
typically the price of a product or a
service doesn't actually take into
account the full cost of producing it
because some resources have
inadvertently been given free to the
producers the land has been polluted and
the workers health destroyed but the
consumer isn't paying we talked a lot
about low prices we don't talk enough
about just prices a just price is the
price that is correctly factored in the
true costs of production in a good
society the just price would be the
normal price whenever a supplier
provides something below the just price
whenever there is as we wrongly call it
a bargain a shortcut is being taken
somewhere the company has to be
offloading some of the cost
they must be treating someone badly they
must be skimping on quality without
admitting it a society gets collectively
more moral we should take immense care
about the path any product took on its
way to our lives in a good business the
price of the product should reflect the
cost of supplying a thing while treating
everyone and everything even the trees
in the rivers kindly along the way
80% of business should in a perfect
world come from the top 20% of our needs
at present the overwhelming share of
business activity is directed at meeting
the lower basic needs moving about
energy food shelter a present capitalism
is mainly directed at the bottom layers
of Abraham Maslow's famous pyramid of
needs we understand we have higher needs
for love self-esteem creativity and so
on but we don't usually imagine that
commerce can help us we've got a
prejudice that paying for something
can't be connected to goodness but it
could be the fact is Commerce has only
barely scratch the list of our true
needs we need to live in beautiful
cities we need to have good advice and
psychological support we need to manage
our emotions we need to sustain strong
families across generations we need to
cultivate our minds we need to live in
societies in which it's normal to be
wise kind and self-possessed these are
vast immense undertakings and we have
collectively a huge way to go the fact
that these ambitions don't look the same
as constructing highways or building
pipelines doesn't at all mean that
they're divorced from work business or
Commerce
their goods and services which have to
be created by ingenuity organization and
effort in short I work far from worrying
about what we might do when there is no
more work we should be preparing
ourselves for almost endless labor to
reach the true goal widespread
fulfillment it's entirely understandable
that many people are disillusioned with
capitalism because business as we
currently know it is not as good as it
should be our objection is not in fact
to business as such but to business
that's bad the response is not therefore
to wish that business would go away but
to work to improve it so that one day it
comes to properly satisfiers as
consumers and as producers
you